hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
time for the Monday morning podcast for
Monday May 25th 2019 what's going on how
are you I'm in a [ __ ] great mood this
Monday 121 days no [ __ ] bows on
Wednesday I'll be a third through the
year already 33 [ __ ] percent 33.5
whatever the [ __ ] mean thirty-three
point three three three three three
three repeating through the year just
like that I feel great
you know it's funny it was we had some
people over here yesterday I got some
family in town so we had a little
cookout and you know I needed some space
on this table so we could prep some [ __ ]
so I took all my booze and I just I
brought it out of the kitchen I just
took it upstairs and put it in the
bedroom
and you know just so we have another
area Prague now it's not the biggest
[ __ ] kitchen right so [ __ ] little
prep area to cook so I [ __ ] last
night I'm going to bed and my new thing
I swear to God to go to sleep
rather than they have three [ __ ]
scotches like I used to as I actually
read I swear to god I'm reading I'm
sober and I'm reading how [ __ ] funny
is that so I I finished this book on Bob
Cousy and Bill Russell that I really
enjoyed and I'm gonna give it to a buddy
of mine because I don't like keeping
books they're [ __ ] heavy they take up
space and I always act like I'm gonna go
back and read them again and I I don't
so now I'm reading the The Beastie Boy
book hardcover edition and as I was
taking the plastic off I was thinking
like it's just gonna affect the value of
it and it's just like bill when do you
sell anything on eBay never alright cool
so I was reading that and all I had was
my little reading light on it my bed and
I looked over and I had a bottle of
yippie-ki-yay right the burb absolutely
delicious unopened just sitting there
and
way the light was hitting it and the way
it was passing through the bottle it
literally looked like it like like a
sunrise and I would be lying to you if I
didn't sort of sit up in bed and just
look at it for a hard 20 seconds and I
was just oh my god yeah I was like that
looks [ __ ] delicious but I didn't but
I will tell you this I'm gonna get it
out of the bedroom though I don't need
to be staring at that late at night you
know all I need to do is have a tough
day and then have those bottles looking
at me sitting there like any bill will
help you take the edge off come on one
drink every 121 days that's not a bad
thing is it simple tastes come on come
on taste
anyways plowing ahead so I'm gonna get
that [ __ ] out of there I also I ordered
a one of those pitch packs which I
haven't had since I was a kid well you
you know you it's you throw the ball
it's like basically just like a net and
it records back you can either get
grounders fly balls or it can come back
straight you know like you actually have
a friend to play catch with and I've
since my [ __ ] up my shoulder which is
feeling great now by the way since I
messed it up I've been I switched to
become an Aleph tee and I just want to
get my mechanics down I'm almost [ __ ]
there where I can get a little velocity
on it so that's basic what I'm basically
living like a goddamn eight-year-old and
I love it
I absolutely love it and you know we're
up this week we're doing episode number
8 of f is for family 408 written by
yours truly
I've eight out of ten so this season as
far as like the heavy lifting the
writing aspect of it is almost over very
thankful for that and we've always had a
killer writer writers room and I think
this year is our strongest room it just
keeps getting better and better I think
that it helps that the show's been on
for as long as it has so writers come in
to the room now just hitting the ground
running they just understand the
characters and all that so it's been
it's definitely been great so with that
I have some new dates I have two and now
announced let's see here I am going to
be at the Cosmopolitan in Las Vegas on
September 6th venue and Ticketmaster
presale is Thursday March 28th the
public on sale is Friday March 29th I
don't know what that means the public
can't go to Ticketmaster all presale
Jesus Christ there's always somebody
board and before group one isn't there
anyways yeah I'm gonna be out there I'm
gonna do a gig and then the following
day I'm gonna go see Elton John cuz I
know this is like his last tour a lot of
people wrapping it up out there a lot of
people wrapping it up out there on their
[ __ ] tours and so I'm like [ __ ] I got
to go see these people before the date
they just don't tour anymore and then
they die and I I know you thinking how
many times can you get suckered into
that bill how many [ __ ] times can
somebody say it's their last [ __ ]
tour and then they come back around
again you know listen I forgive it if
you get into some sort of tax trouble
you know what I mean [ __ ] taxes Jesus
Christ
Jesus did I start a shitstorm on [ __ ]
reddit when I was talking about the that
taxing people 70% money north of 10
million dollars and I am passionately
against that I don't make north of 10
million dollars but I also know how
taxes work all right
so they'll create that and then a few
years later they'll be like well people
who make eight to ten should play this
people who make six to eight should pay
this and it's just gonna trickle all the
[ __ ] way down yeah seventy percent
there's no justification for it on any
level that is absolute [ __ ] rape and
people who are saying that the
20 trillion dollars that is in offshore
accounts is a complete separate issue
isn't I completely disagree that's
basically like you have a house and the
foundation is cracked and you're worried
that the house is gonna fall into the
front yard and you're sitting there
going we need to raise money to paint
the [ __ ] thing and it's like no dude
we need to fix the foundation and you're
like that's a separate issue technically
I guess it is a separate issue but it's
like it's it's a more important issue
you're gonna paint something that's
gonna fall down on its [ __ ] face all
right if you're gonna sit there and
ignore that and you're going to ignore
the fact that corporations are dictating
our foreign policy and have bankrupted
this country this country is [ __ ]
bankrupt right now and they're not
bankrupt
we're not bankrupt because people who
make ten million dollars or more are not
paying seventy percent taxes we're
[ __ ] bankrupt because we're spending
a billion dollars over a billion dollars
a [ __ ] month fighting some [ __ ] that
we could actually solve here we could
just convert to [ __ ] solar power if
oil companies didn't own the politicians
you could convert to that give the solar
power give the [ __ ] Sun to the oil
companies so they can still have their
eyes wide shut [ __ ] parties and I'm
not saying solar power is cleaner it
doesn't [ __ ] [ __ ] up the ocean when
you throw the big [ __ ] things in
there or whatever I'm not saying that
but I'm just saying it would solve the
Middle East problem because all of that
[ __ ] terrorism is funded with oil
money and nobody uses more of it than us
so let's just switch over I know that's
a it's a it's a [ __ ] not an easy
endeavor but do it like [ __ ] Ilan
must put these little [ __ ] glow
sticks in the goddamn road we'll do that
not for a cleaner earth just to get its
the [ __ ] out of there because right now
they have us all walking around like
zombies going I support the Jew support
your throat all right support the troops
right who doesn't support the [ __ ]
home team but they take it to the point
where you can't question where you're
sending the troops and for how [ __ ]
long and you can't even bring up
hey guys were [ __ ] bankrupt this
isn't working
separate issue separate issue let's
[ __ ] rape the guy that started Dollar
Shave Club that's the solution and let
me guess let me guess these are the tax
dollars that's are actually gonna make
it to public schools these are the tax
dollars that are gonna pay for
nationwide health care these are the
text all is they're gonna [ __ ] yet I
take over our food supply again so it's
not people you know little girls aren't
getting their period at ten years old
because of all the [ __ ] hormones in
it like you're gonna sit there you want
to put money on that this is two tax
dollars it's going to be spent right
that these [ __ ] [ __ ] correct
piece of [ __ ] politicians aren't gonna
steal the [ __ ] out of here dude this
people in this country making eighty to
a hundred million dollars that are
paying zero percent taxes zero percent
taxes go look up Apple I got an apple
laptop right here it's sitting right in
front of me go look up how they
successfully avoids paying 50 billion in
American taxes hey gay guys separate
issue separate [ __ ] issue all these
corporations making money hand over
[ __ ] fist and as such greedy [ __ ]
[ __ ] they won't pay dollar number one
on fifty billion dollars oh yeah no no
no [ __ ] that [ __ ] that let's go after
[ __ ] individual Americans who had the
balls to go after a [ __ ] look let's
just look at stand-up comedians I I
would if somebody told me the percentage
I can't imagine the percentage that
actually make it you know and I was that
guy in my mid to late thirties sitting
on a [ __ ] futon no wife no kids in a
[ __ ] studio apartment sitting knowing
that I'm in a young man's game going
where the [ __ ] does this go do it if I
don't [ __ ] make it you know I'm gonna
end up on [ __ ] cruise ships in my 50s
and 60s fighting every night to not
throw my
over the [ __ ] railing all right and I
had the balls to stay in it but because
I did you're now gonna [ __ ] punish me
and demonize you no and I'm not saying I
don't make that money but I know how
this game works that is gonna start at
ten and then it's gonna [ __ ] work its
way down and then what you're gonna have
is my voice is cracking what you're
gonna have is a literally a wall between
ridiculously unbelievably [ __ ] rich
people who are paying no taxes and then
you're gonna push the rest of everybody
else back down and have a solve fighting
with one another with all of these
[ __ ] people who sent me emails who
were just saying they've never heard me
be so greedy like I'm greedy
how [ __ ] funny is that I'm greedy
with what my money the money that I
earned I'm [ __ ] greedy with that and
you who it isn't your [ __ ] money a
telling me to give it to you and I'm the
[ __ ] greedy one and meanwhile you're
gonna completely ignore this other
subset of people who are paying and tell
me that that's a separate [ __ ] issue
I'm not the guy who poisoned the [ __ ]
food supply I'm not the one who's
pouring [ __ ] into our drinking water I'm
not the one who runs a company that
makes 50 billion [ __ ] dollars and I
got lawyers a team of [ __ ] lawyers
figuring out how I can pay zero dollars
okay I don't have a [ __ ] sweatshop
where people are trying to jump to that
death and rather than pay a
[ __ ] money I put Nets outside
of the [ __ ] factory so they just land
in that and I can yank them out of the
net and stick them back at their [ __ ]
workstation I'm not the guy doing that
but you're gonna sit there and tell me
that that's a separate [ __ ] issue is
it a separate issue or is it just more
difficult to police so you're gonna go
for the [ __ ] layup
un-fuckin'-believable it's a separate
issue I'll sit there all day and listen
to your [ __ ] point
until you say it's a separate issue
paying taxes and paying your fair share
is is [ __ ] straight across the board
this same issue and if you're gonna go
after people who are already paying more
than 50% taxes on their [ __ ] income
which is [ __ ] criminal in my world
that the person who does the job has to
give away more than they made they get
to keep less than what they [ __ ] made
and they did the [ __ ] job and you're
gonna sit there and tell me that that's
fair the [ __ ] out of here
I'll never agree with that but I will
read your [ __ ] emails all of these
[ __ ] politicians are all in these
[ __ ] people's back pockets don't
[ __ ] believe these goddamn [ __ ]
people who come along and say I like
Trump I'm gonna I'm gonna clean up the
so I'm gonna drain the swamp he hasn't
taken a [ __ ] he hasn't taken a Dixie
cup worth of water out of that [ __ ]
swamp alright because this is what we
all want to [ __ ] to ignore to really
change that you would have to have an
all-out [ __ ] revolution and there
would have to be bloodshed and the only
people that really have the ability to
do it would be those lunatics in
Blackwater they would be the only guys
who'll be able to do it all you have to
do is cross your fingers and pray that
they're decent [ __ ] human beings
because they actually have the weaponry
to pull it off other than that all
you're gonna do is [ __ ] go after
innocent [ __ ] people which is what
you guys are some of you are [ __ ]
advocating while you ignore the [ __ ]
9000 pound gorilla in the room who's
paying zero dollars in taxes all right
I'm done until I read it more later on
did you guys watch any of the I think
someone who makes 50 grand a year should
be paying 59 percent taxes all right did
you guys watch it you guys watch the
Duke for Central Florida game oh my god
what a [ __ ] heartbreaker that was I
didn't know what to do because I love
Duke but I also root for an underdog and
it was in the end of that game it was
like the basketball gods
just chose [ __ ] Duke you know that
alley-oop I don't know if we look like
it was mistimed I don't know what and
then the [ __ ] Duke misses it and then
gets the [ __ ] rebound and then the
shot in the end and the tip-in just
didn't flow just didn't want to [ __ ]
go in you know I'll tell you right now
if you're a [ __ ] NBA fan you're
missing out you're missing out in what's
left of college basketball because
there's so many one-and-done it's just a
pleasure to watch that level of talent
and they're actually listening to their
coach because that's just what's missing
in the [ __ ] NBA this [ __ ] [ __ ]
where it's just like you do these guys
and they make so much [ __ ] money that
that they they feel like they don't have
to listen to their coach I just don't
understand it's like you're a platoon
and that's the general and he's coming
in with the fight plan and you're like
yeah now we're just gonna improv this
we're just gonna go we're all gonna go
in there and just start open fire and
you know in the same general [ __ ]
direction I just feel like when you do
that that's when a team that on paper
isn't as good as you can come in and
you're open yourself up to getting beat
that's what it is meant that is that is
that is that how the NBA game is played
now it is the individual [ __ ] game
it's the an one influence on the game
which I'm not on a percent against that
level of [ __ ] creativity and
one-on-one and all that type of [ __ ] but
like you know when you have like a coach
just sitting there with his [ __ ]
thumbs up his ass because he can only
talk to the lower [ __ ] 70% of the
team you know what I mean it's almost
like those superstars are like Apple
right don't pay that taxes they don't
want to they think they think they're
above being coached
anyways everything's gonna go back to
that I've been paying attention to the
Premier League Liverpool is still two
points ahead but I looked up the
schedule this time because I thought
that they were in the lead that's just
they've played more games they have nine
games left and Man City has 11 games
left and as far as I can tell none of
them really have that really much
challenging games left other than Man
City plays Man United that could be the
fly in the ointment game there so I'll
try to pay attention I'll watch that
game because I figure that's going to be
a big one and then I'm gonna be watching
the Bruins first Tampa Bay Lightning
tonight that's gonna be my that's gonna
be my little [ __ ] my little evening
tonight and I mentioned last week I went
I went to the premier that motley crue
movie the dirt definitely check it out
just to [ __ ] awe I really loved the
movie didn't pull any punches and I
actually saw some woman in the LA Times
which was given one of the band members
[ __ ] going like how could you put a
movie out post me - how could you put a
movie out like this and the dude was
like well I mean it happened you want us
to rewrite history was like the perfect
[ __ ] answer and if you watch it
what's so [ __ ] up is it's it's all
consensual sex it's just a bunch of
people over indulging so if we gotten
literally to this point that a that a
bunch of guys playing in a band who have
a bunch of groupies who want to [ __ ] the
[ __ ] out of them so they do is like a
bad [ __ ] is like somehow like that there
was something wrong there I mean you
could say there was something wrong as
far as like what everybody was doing
there if you want to get into some sort
of religious debate about morals leave
if you want to get out of religion and
just talk about the emptiness of living
a life like that how it's exciting in
the beginning but then afterwards
there's a profound loneliness to living
a life like that for both people the
groupie and the [ __ ] rock star I can
have that [ __ ] conversation with
but I don't understand how that [ __ ]
you know I thought me to was you took
your dick out at working just on a plant
right it was in that world right wasn't
playing some songs and chicks in the
crowd is showing that titties to you
then afterwards you bang him I I didn't
think that that that fell under that
[ __ ] umbrella there's me to basically
also get to the point of like you know
that men can't go out and enjoy
themselves if they're out there and they
if you play in a band it's gonna it's
rain you know that's gonna happen
there's actually people that got into
bands just for the chicks and all of a
sudden that [ __ ] their bands somehow
[ __ ] made it
and this standing up there without a
within their passion his [ __ ] look at
gene Simmons I've never heard that guy
talked passionately about music he just
talks passionately about women and he's
so obsessed with it he literally says
dumb [ __ ] like anybody who says they got
into a bed for the music is a [ __ ]
liar they got in it for the [ __ ] I mean
it that's out that far down the [ __ ]
road that guy is if everybody doesn't
share my opinion then they're [ __ ]
lying
anyways yeah it was it was 30 40 [ __ ]
years ago
and you know I don't know Motley Crue
did what a lot of bands did and they
made a [ __ ] movie about it and even
then it's sort of like they kind of
glossed over a lot of it so I don't
understand what the [ __ ] problem is
there's always somebody now that's got
some sort of problems don't you think
that that movie about seagulls doesn't
doesn't misses the mark about the main
issue the main issue being the issue
that I'm concerned with by the way my
favorite thing right now on the Internet
as crystally as that thing he did that
thing he's trying to start jokingly or
not called the unfollowing follow chris
d'elia on instagram and scroll through
I'm sure he's made a couple videos since
his last one he did this [ __ ] thing I
was talking about I think I just talked
about this but I just want to promote it
again because I think it's like all
those Instagram models you know he goes
yay he goes make no mistake if you're on
Instagram and you taking pictures of
your booty and your titties yeah hook he
literally breaks it down to all of this
[ __ ] that I didn't even know existed I
guess you know hot chicks biting into a
giant sandwich like looking up in the
air trying to be trying to be cute or
something like that and it's like I know
he's just saying to unfollow them which
is [ __ ] funny to me
because I'm not in that world at all but
I was talking to younger comics about
this and I you know they run into these
people I guess and they were saying like
yeah they actually come up to you and
have like an attitude like they're doing
something now they are doing something
they are going to the gym they are
keeping themselves in shape and God
bless them in an entrepreneurial way I
respect the fact that they're building a
brand here but I don't I don't cosign on
then walking around acting like an
egotistical maniac if that's what the
[ __ ] they're doing I don't [ __ ] know
there's so much [ __ ] on there that's
[ __ ] hilarious I saw somebody made
made a post where they were talking with
women's day and of course they were like
you know [ __ ] that it should be women's
day every day of the year which is
hilarious because it's just like and
when would it be guys day then does that
seem fair to you and the person like
took like a [ __ ] picture and it's
like a sexy picture like they couldn't
just make their statement they also had
to show off their [ __ ] you know their
flat stomach and their [ __ ] ass and
stuff it's just like it's like what are
what are we doing here it's like if that
exact picture if a guy used it to sell
like like you know some coca-cola it'd
be like objectifying women Joe did you
heed what needs to change but then you
know I don't know but then you can do it
if it's you doing it to yourself selling
women's day I don't know I don't I don't
get how the [ __ ] math works but you
know something I was never good at math
all I can tell you this is I don't think
LeBron James should have to give away
70% of his money over 10 million dollars
I don't I don't I think he's already
[ __ ] paying well over 50 Tom Brady
all of these [ __ ] people and I think
you know something I think you're paying
your fair share at that point how much
more [ __ ] money do you want to take
from these [ __ ] people while ignoring
people who are paying no money in taxes
why ignoring companies that are leading
us off into war that has no end that
bankrupts the country that's a separate
issue oh Jesus all right let me read
some advertising here eh my bookie hey I
look funky doin I write brackets first
round upsets the final four March
Madness is here right there on your
television screen it's time to bet with
the best at my bookie hey would you
rather sit at your office desk or call
out sick and binge on NCAA tournament
games and junk food like that's okay or
let's see would you would you rabbits
I'm the worst would you rather sit at
your office desk or call out sick and
binge on NCAA Tournament games and junk
food like that's even a choice I love
how these guys they're not even trying
to hide how degenerate they are gamble
on sports and don't go to work don't
even have an apple eat some Fritos
anyway sometimes it feels good to be bad
that's the balance of life especially
when it's with someone you trust and if
you're looking for a place to get in on
the action you can trust my bookie
they've been
business for years and they're growing
like wildfire the best part is they pay
out fast so when you call that twelve
over five upset this year make sure to
celebrate
you'll be pocketing cold hard cash core
talking points March Madness is the most
exciting action-packed sporting event of
the year even grandmothers fill out
brackets place your bets with my bookie
now before you miss out my bad my bookie
will match your deposit with a 50% bonus
use promo code bird to activate the
offer visit my bookie AG today you play
you win you get paid only at my bookie
dot AG all right oh look who's here
Oh zip hiring used to be hard oh my god
it's so difficult you know writing we're
hiring on a sign sticking it in a window
hoping that dream person walked by and
they need a job it ain't like that
anymore alright with zip recruiter zip
recruiter sends you wait sends your job
to over 100 of the web's leading job
boards but they don't stop there with
their powerful matching technology zip
[Music]
scans thousands of job resumes to find
out people with the right experience and
invite them to apply to your job as
applications come in
Zipporah analyzes each one and spots
lights the top candidates so you never
miss a great match zip is so effective
that 80% of employees who post on zip
get a quality candidate through the site
within the first day and right now my
listeners can try zip recruiter for free
at the exclusive website address zip
recruiter comm / / that zip recruiter
com / / one more time
zip / / zi p r ec rui
we are the smartest way to hire oh Jesus
we got a lot today what do we got here
what do we what do we have here you know
what I got one two three left so I'm
gonna break them up I'll read the third
one here we'll get over the hump this is
Wednesday here simply safe hi fellas
here's something interesting studies
show that security systems deter
burglars
it's a fact but there's still a burglary
every eight seconds in America how well
think about it think about it do
burglars give up just because some house
why houses have security systems of
course not they just find a house that
isn't protected
that's why securing your home is truly
necessary so wait a minute so if
everybody ends up getting a security
system then these guys are going to have
to up their gain like a virus because of
you know if you don't kill the virus you
just keep using the medicine they get
immune to it we have to kill the virus
so simply safe what I would be doing if
I was them I would eventually I would
come with up with a security system that
not only deters the intruder it also
kills them all right but that's a
different read simply safe sensors will
protect every point of access up to your
home doors windows garage you name it
yeah if a burglar even tries to break in
and ear-shattering son remember those
old sci-fi things where they would shoot
like a sound ray and somebody they would
just grab both there is Jesus Christ I
just pictured the burglar dressed like
Captain Kirk best of all simply saves 24
you wouldn't want him and is your
[ __ ] house you try to bang your wife
best of all simply safes 24/7 monitoring
is just $14.99 a month and they'll never
lock you in a long-term contract more
than three million people already know
it feels good to fear less was simply
safe so go with the only home security
system you can trust simply safe by
going to simply saber combi URR
go today and get free shipping and a 60
day money back guarantee
that's simply safe bird comm for home
security si
MP L I sa Fe bird comm alright let's
plow ahead
alright Cubans rolled too tight hey
Billy suctions face if you're Cubans
turn your face purple when you smoke
them then they are probably counterfeit
I know people tell me that but you know
something I have to be honest with you I
get a lot of Dominicans I get a lot of
Nicaraguans and I run into the same
problem not the same problem with the
Cubans so it's somebody making fake
Nicaraguans and Dominicans anyways the
demand for Cuban cigars
far outweighs the availability is
another thing too sir I [ __ ] I've
smoked him in different countries and
I've had run into the same problem maybe
you're saying the worldwide demand which
you're probably right so they are often
faked in nearly indistinguishable from
the real deal even for the trained eye
it's only when you start smoking them
that it's noticeable rolling a good
cigar is a true art which is not
mastered by counterfeiters looking for a
quick buck
the demand for Dominicans for example is
a lot lower and they are not cannot
consider extremely rare or valuable they
are rarely counterfeit greetings from
Ghent Belgium and as per usual
go [ __ ] yourself well he is in Belgium
so yeah yeah I gotta be honest with you
I'm kind of getting away from the Cubans
because they're they're really expensive
and I'm at one time when I was in
Australia I must have got the real deal
because I bought these Cohibas and when
I came back they they were they were
incredible like they were a cigar that
as you were lighting it like the first
couple puffs you went oh my god oh my
god that's believe me what'd you do your
whole body [ __ ] relaxes and it's
amazing having said that I would like to
quit those that might be the next
thing that I want to do and I am I am I
would like to just replace all my vices
with something a little more healthy and
then eventually come back to a vice that
isn't a bad vice what's your vice you
know I guess I I think I read too much
in bad lighting I have to stop I know
I'm so bad I need to go to meetings like
I'd love to be that [ __ ] person you
know so eventually I think I'm gonna
like get down to maybe like three four
cigars a year the Rose Bowl the big
college game my birthday and then
something around Christmas and just sort
of leave it at that because I am really
getting into living like a [ __ ] nerd
you know it's underrated never overrated
underrated I'll tell you underrated
reading a great book at night to make
you sleepy
rather than staring at a screen and I've
kind of realized that one of my vices is
the amount of time that I spend on my
phone and I want to get used to like not
being you know like I'll be in the car
and I just find myself going over and
picking it up like like a [ __ ] child
with with its little favorite teddy bear
and [ __ ] sitting there looking at the
goddamn screen and it's like I'm driving
scrolling trying to find a song so I
think what I'm gonna I try to put it in
airplane mode but then most of my songs
are on the [ __ ] cloud and then I lose
all my goddamn music so now what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna have a playlist
download those you know ten songs or
whatever and then put it on airplane
mode and then literally take the thing
and [ __ ] throw it in the backseat I
would like to do that and but I'll tell
you man underrated [ __ ] reading I'm
back into it and and I told you I had
this woman tell me that I wasn't gonna
be able to learn French so I'm back to
the flashcards and stuff
and I got a couple friends of mine that
can speak French so we only text each
other
strictly in French and I'm not I'm
really starting to learn this [ __ ] I
can't speak it well but I can read it
really well now or at least to another
level and it's I mean I could [ __ ] be
doing that rather than slowly killing
myself and killing brain cells and [ __ ]
and I don't know man I think you know
like I had that cookout yesterday and
there was a bunch of people over and
[ __ ] and I was stoned [ __ ] sober so
then you know as I'm walking around and
then I run into my kid hey are you doing
I'm not like buzzed there's a low point
in your [ __ ] life you know having a
little buzz going then you see your
[ __ ] kid it's just like what am i
doing what if something happens right
now and I need to react and I'm a little
buzzed right now I just can't [ __ ] do
it anymore the guilt of it I can't
handle it so anyways I agree with you
sir I like the the Casa Magnus the I
swear to God I think they're called
colleague Leah like that [ __ ] half a
porno movie
I like the aurora emeralds and there's a
couple of my father cigars that I really
like but I don't know I'm gonna be
basically trying to phase those [ __ ]
out alright card games and board games
hey Bill catching up on the podcast I
heard you had fun playing cards yeah I
loved it
played with my mom it was awesome you
should check out the word the world of
card games and board games there's a
regular popular game called Five Crowns
that's a rummy style game that is fun
also board games have come a long way I
feel like you may have been a risk guy I
was I love that game
taken over the world though I don't
recall you saying it oh I love that
[ __ ] game there are great strategy
games out there that are fun to play
with friends and cigars
people love Settlers of Catan or Catan a
game that has probably sold thriller
like numbers
in the tabletop game world I'm gonna
check that out hey you know what I
missed
I lost let me see if I that meditation
[ __ ] music I lost it ah you [ __ ]
[ __ ] bill I was really looking
forward to that [ __ ] god damn I'll be
able to find it I guess it's just that
music that goes on for like [ __ ]
three hours or I can just go back and
listen to my old pot you know ISM is
amazing here I don't I don't even know
how to [ __ ] so I just unplug something I
don't even know how to [ __ ] listen of
my own podcast how pathetic you said
alright I'll definitely be checking
these things out he says there's a game
called secret Hitler
that's pretty involved I'm not sure
you'd have time in your schedule but
it's worth looking at secret there's a
game called secret Hitler object find
the person in the game who's had who's
starting the final solution again even
the classics are fun to revisit monopoly
life etc yeah I love that stuff my kid
gets a little bit bigger I want to start
playing those games have a game night we
already have the night where we go out
this will kill my stand-up career game
now I can't I can't do that gig I've
game night I can't do that gig I have to
go out for I have to go out take my
family out for dinner hey by the way
anybody who lives in LA and you know
some really good mom-and-pop places it
doesn't have to be healthy or anything
what in the [ __ ] is that all it's a cat
Jesus Christ I thought it was a raccoon
I just saw a [ __ ] cat just came up in
the [ __ ] window through the blinds
he was like looking in like it was gonna
do something cats a creepy man they just
they just are man they just always think
they they think too much you look at a
dog it's it's not [ __ ] thinking about
anything cats just had that [ __ ] that
they're plotting you know very female
energy Debbie just sit next to your
girlfriend you just feel I'm thinking
you're like a [ __ ] here we go
here we go what's wrong now what the
[ __ ] is wrong now or a girlfriend
forcing me to go vegan speaking of which
I bet that guy fell turd thinking first
of all before we even get into this your
girlfriend cannot force you to do
anything you need to [ __ ] eat a steak
in front of her and say listen you
either love me or you don't I already
know this solution to this alright hey
Billy long time listener and first time
I've written in as I desperately need
some advice my girl and I have been
together for about eight months she's
awesome and I get laid about three times
a week alright um weird sentence things
have gradually gotten more serious and
we now spend most evenings together
eating dinner even though we don't stay
over with each other every night well
that's good that's healthy that you
still have a little bitty independence
we mostly eat dinner at her place so she
does the grocery shopping and she's also
vegan which isn't bad dude she's you
know provided she's buying you know I
guess organic how do you even tell if
it's organic because I've heard from a
lot of people and this might come from
the meat industry I have no idea but
I've heard from a lot of people that you
know the amount of pesticides they spray
on them sometimes actually eating some
iceberg lettuce might be more for you
than even a [ __ ] pig who knows also
she's a vegan she recently decided that
she was not going to buy meat for me so
it's easy to cook plus it's better for
the environment and my health basically
all the [ __ ] arguments vegans use
against us carnivores yell the cows
farting it up into the atmosphere
I do love me but also love this girl and
would honestly go vegan for should I
just be done with it and cut cut it meat
I'll see you I think you might say cut
out meat or am i setting setting the
tone for the whole relationship to get
treated like a little [ __ ] appreciate
your advice all right I like that you're
asking these questions sir so you're
still in a healthy place mentally that's
what I would say to her just be like
listen
I'm willing to do this for us but I'm
also I would be lying to you if I wasn't
nervous that I was setting a tone that
you know if say you don't like March
Madness that I'm grad I'm eventually
gonna stop watching it
so you got to do it the funnier way than
that I don't know I don't think going
vegan if the person knows what the [ __ ]
they're doing because there's a lot of
fat vegetarians out there who are eating
chips and she's made for potatoes but
you know they're not necessarily healthy
you know when they're carbon it up I
know there's a lot of fake meat and [ __ ]
out there now there's a lot of there's a
lot of ways to go I am not nearly it
read enough on this subject to give you
any sort advice as which way to go but I
think your concern is correct I would
just go slow I would just say alright
look if you just want to cook vegan here
and then I would just which isn't bad
it's not bad to take a break for meat I
wouldn't think I don't know I but I I
also know that it ii really do do the
vegan thing correctly i actually you
know something to be a meat-eater and
and and just eat up to just really eat
well is you borderline need a [ __ ]
degree in something first of all you got
to be half a [ __ ] private eye to try
and figure out where the organic [ __ ] is
because everything now is free-range
everything is [ __ ] organic the amount
of chickens that they say a [ __ ]
free-range but there's still those
[ __ ] arnold schwarzenegger roided-up
[ __ ] chickens because I remember when
I watched that that documentary I figure
out what the [ __ ] it was called not you
are what you eat something about food
and I saw I was like man [ __ ] this I got
to go find an organic chicken dude I
mean I
a farmers market and then I had to sift
through all the [ __ ] there and get
people to honestly tell me this guy
finally almost like he had the Cuban
dough actual real Cubans in the back and
when he held up when he showed me a what
a real chicken looks like it look I
thought was like is that him what is
that a [ __ ] pigeon it's like no
that's that's that's what they're
supposed to look like it looked like I
plight a football player in the 1930s
versus one in the [ __ ] 80s and 90s
when they were [ __ ] all roided up not
like then that's not doing roids no oh
speaking of which football players
congratulations to Rob Gronkowski going
out as a champion thank you so much for
all your [ __ ] everything you did over
the years playing for the Patriots and I
actually think it's a great move
especially when you see you know the
results of playing the game and all that
I think he's leaving at a perfect time
he's got his money he was really taking
a lot of hits basically below the waist
which was the only way to get him down
and they were just chopping his [ __ ]
legs down and he was probably sick of
going into surgeries and being hurt and
all of that and just the fact that the
last game he played he made the biggest
[ __ ] play that big catch that got us
to touchdown that put us over the top
and won us our six Super Bowl yeah Hall
of Fame New England Patriot without a
doubt I don't know you know I don't
collect football cards anymore so I
don't know what his his numbers are but
I I got a good feeling about the actual
Pro Football Hall of Fame Academy so and
I also did a roast with them one time
and he was such a [ __ ] cool guy and
there's a lot of people out there that
think he's this big dumb guy and he
isn't I remember I was talking to him
about we were talking about going to
concerts and he was saying how much he
[ __ ] hated how people were sitting
there videoing their experience rather
than having the experience he's going
like it's like you're there enjoy the
experience and all I remember thinking
in that going I wish people could hear
this [ __ ] conversation so that you
know because there was just think they
always think that about big [ __ ]
people that they they're [ __ ] dumb he
not he was not and he did great on the
roast ban he was funny you know anyway
so plowing ahead here I would you know I
would use this thing as an opportunity
to basically yet set some boundaries in
your relationship in a funny way and
just be like all right you know what
I'll be beacon when I'm at your house
and if you know she's pushing you to
become vegan and your house just be like
you know I I really enjoy a steak I
really do and I'm gonna keep eating it
and if you're gonna break up with me
over a pork chop then they're probably
really wasn't love here in the first
place
meanwhile you know read up on [ __ ]
nutrition I mean I'm giving you advice
that I should be takin I should read up
on a two because I've been eating really
well over the last year and now that
I've no I should say since July and I
had somebody put together a diet for me
and I pretty much loosely use that with
some of my older bad habits I'm not
gonna lie to you and and just cutting
out the booze it's been really easy to
sort of maintain a decent body weight
it's probably the smartest thing that
you could [ __ ] do learn how to defend
yourself and learn how to eat right you
know figure out why you [ __ ] up so you
don't take it out on somebody else and
go out and go find a great person and
then work on the relationship like this
person is doing rather than bailing
because I actually have a theory about
divorce where I think a lot of them they
could have fixed it if they just were
working on it along the way and then you
just start thinking like oh this
person's a [ __ ] [ __ ] and then you
just have this fantasy that you're gonna
meets it you're just basically chasing
that feeling you had when you both met
each other in the beginning and you just
never gonna be brand new you just have
to accept that but you can get back to
different levels of emotional Heights if
you actually work on it like the dumbest
thing ever just you doin [ __ ] like you
know up family dinner night and
everybody puts the way their phones or
whatever and it's just you or if you're
single or whatever you're not married
you can go out to a movie
and I'm telling you turning off your
phone is a [ __ ] huge thing then I've
discovered especially if you've got
[ __ ] massive a DD like me okay where
are we here Big Sugar alright I can't
tell if this is a place to go skiing or
there's just more stuff about food hey
Billy bald balls last week or so you
went off on one email proposing a
massive tax on the rich
no I didn't no I did not I went off on a
massive tax on honest Americans okay
this is not a tax on the rich this is a
tax on people who are not smart enough
or corrupt enough to have their money in
offshore accounts that's what I went off
on he said then I learned about how tax
dollars are feeding billions to sugar
industry the US government has
subsidized the domestic sugar industry
so much that domestic sugar prices are
up to 50 percent more than their
international counterparts the
government does this by establishing
quotas that limit imports so now more
domestic production means that there is
more farmland to take up by sugar yeah
which is people are starting to say as a
carcinogen there's nothing to when you
cut sugar out of your diet like I've
been having this [ __ ] almond butter I
know big Hollywood [ __ ] phony you
have to apologize for trying to eat
right right it's like when I drove a
Prius everybody [ __ ] you know saying
I was homophobic [ __ ] to me because I
was because you're just reminding people
that hey man the way we're doing this
[ __ ] is steering us into the [ __ ] Sun
here anyways
my wife had bought some peanut butter
for my daughter and it was just the
regular kind and I you know we ran out
of almond butter and I put some on some
toast and I bit into it and I have
fortunately such little amount of sugar
my diet that I bit into it like I
literally like might [ __ ] my mouth
puckered like Jesus Christ I had no idea
how much
sugar is in [ __ ] peanut butter it's
insane
anyways he goes if you are wondering why
kids are getting beards at ten then this
might be why these companies don't want
to pay for real sugar
so they just make another sweet poison
and call it sugar free leave I am yeah
yeah yeah the environmental impacts are
also dire with sugar beets causing
worsening soil quality and water
pollution that is much worse than other
crops the worst part of all is is the
insane amount of money these bastards
get like one Florida farm families
getting 150 to 250 million that comes
out of the taxpayers pocket separate
issue also the increased sticker prices
make companies in food processing have
to layoff 10,000 to 20,000 employees a
year while sugar growers can usually
make up to 750 thousand dollars a year
sorry 750 million a year no 750 thousand
a year that's doesn't make any sense I
think you put the wrong number there the
American sugar Alliance is one of the
most funded lobbying groups with a
handful of companies bringing in the
mass amounts of the four billion in
subsidies the taxpayers give I hope you
found this important and interesting and
as always go [ __ ] yourself yeah handful
look at that is one of the most funded
lobbying groups yeah there what do you
think all that money goes do you think
it just goes to the lobbying or do you
think it goes into politicians pet
projects it's [ __ ] ridiculous how
corrupt that is and you're gonna go
after the people who create an app or
people who start movement watches these
are these these people are the [ __ ]
yeah they're the [ __ ] problem you can
ignore all the corruptions so here's a
guy here who's basically gonna [ __ ]
tear me a new [ __ ] alright and I love
the title why I stopped listening and
this is the classic baby that exists now
you know you you know you're you know
you you have a difference of opinion so
you're gonna stop listening you [ __ ]
child is if my words somehow affected
your life like I said that and then what
the IRS is actually going to be going
after these [ __ ] people then not
alright why I stopped listening bill
I've stopped listening to your podcast
are you [ __ ] eight years old I felt
that I should tell you why mmm much like
a restaurant who loses a loyal customer
wants to know why what went wrong you
know you love how he's putting those
words in my mouth like I give a [ __ ]
that an absolute child isn't gonna
listen to my [ __ ] podcast so no hard
feelings but here it is you should like
flip your hair right now like Dee Snider
is that his name the guy from Twisted
Sister when he made that point you know
when he was in front of Congress about
the PMRC man I have never heard a more
selfish mouth-breathing uninformed
money-grubbing [ __ ] speak in my entire
life this is what I love I don't even
mean I don't make ten million dollars a
year I don't make ten million dollars a
year so I was actually defending people
whose tax money would actually go I
guess to help me and somehow I'm
money-grubbing because this person so up
the ass of their own [ __ ] point
they can't even listen to what it is
that I'm saying he goes sometimes you
say something halfway smart but it is
surrounded he says my so much [ __ ]
he's calling me dumb he didn't even hit
the spellcheck buy so much [ __ ] it
makes me feel you stumbled into saying
it by accident yes sir because no one
could ever be as smart as you like how a
monkey banging on a typewriter might
some tile type out Shakespeare I don't
think a monkey banging out a typewriter
it might somehow type out Shakespeare I
think what you meant might meant to say
is that he might accidentally spell a
word correctly like might accidentally
spell the or Act I don't think you meant
Shakespeare all right you know what I'm
finding I think he wrote this in a very
high emotional state here so I'll cut
you some slack and I've always said I'm
a [ __ ]
okay and even now that I'm reading I'm
reading like the [ __ ] Beastie Boy
autobiography I'm reading the [ __ ]
which actually is I'm finding a is is a
history book on a certain genre of music
that I believe the kids call hip-hop
alright the biggest problem is you
cannot see beyond your own experience
making ten million dollars a year is not
my experience I've never made ten
million dollars in a year okay and this
is most evident in your recent diatribe
about the seventy percent tax rate I
don't know I like to think I you know I
don't always but I like to think you
know I try to like listen to both sides
I guess I guess I guess I don't in case
your memory is blinded by your own rage
what about your rage let me go over some
dumbass things that you said on Monday
March eighteenth first of all sir you're
calling me a mouth-breather and you're
saying that I have rage and you're
literally misspelling words and you're
so angry at me right now that you can't
present your opinion without calling me
names anyways you call people making ten
million plus a year regular guys who are
deserving of empathy sure some are your
woe is me lament of these poor poor
millionaires made my blood boil exactly
exactly
look how you just phrased that look at
these poor poor millionaires you're
judging them and who they are because of
how much money they make and you're
gonna turn it into a Disney movie where
anybody who makes money is [ __ ] evil
makes my blood blood boil [ __ ] you this
guy literally just said blinded by a
rage [ __ ] you
you implied that money tax from
millionaires goes directly back to lazy
[ __ ] making less I don't remember
saying that maybe I did maybe I did all
right you said
isn't fair that people being honest with
their income have to pay this rate while
rich people hide their incomes overseas
you also said that tax money is being
waste wasted and then it just says
corrupt [ __ ] I agree with both of
these things these are separate problems
that also need to be fixed
you're often being you're often being
dumb [ __ ] like this up what as if
the government can't do two things at
once okay I think with your [ __ ] half
written email calling me a [ __ ] sir
they're not going after these people
they're not okay it's been deemed too
difficult okay because what they do is
they I already explained this [ __ ] is
how is it explained to me in layman's
term you have a [ __ ] company okay you
have a buy a pile of [ __ ] money
so you crew [ __ ] either incorporate
in a different country or you you create
a fake phony [ __ ] company in that
country which builds your legit company
a ridiculous amount of [ __ ] money so
then you're then able to show that your
company somehow lost money so now you
don't have to pay any taxes but now your
money is in this fake company so how do
you get it right you be have it in this
foreign [ __ ] Island right which is a
different country you pay some people
off there so to let the money go there
then you start another company in a
different Island and then they build
that company and you just keep going
hopscotching through the [ __ ]
Caribbean or wherever the [ __ ] this [ __ ]
goes down alright and then the last
company goes back to you and gives you
like 50 million hundred million dollars
in the form of a loan which is untaek
scible and then you're allegedly gonna
pay it back which you don't and when you
don't
that phony [ __ ] company forgives the
loan that's the base that in layman's
terms that's the
it was explained to me and the problem
is is that with each one of those
islands that it goes through its it's a
whole new [ __ ] it's a different
country a different government and you
have to go through a mountain of red
tape so they have seven ten fourteen of
these [ __ ] companies all ping-pong
and all through the [ __ ] islands and
it just be it just it's too difficult
it's too difficult and then what you
have is honest [ __ ] people who took a
[ __ ] chance okay and risk basically
sleeping alone on a [ __ ] futon with
no wife no [ __ ] family maxed out
their [ __ ] credit cards and most of
those people lose and then you're gonna
come in to take there's no way you can
present an argument or seventy million
dot seventy percent
paying taxes on one [ __ ] dollar
seventy percent you cannot set that
[ __ ] precedent by the government okay
considering their complete corrupt
pieces of [ __ ] a stand-up comedian is
not a corrupt piece of [ __ ] okay he's
not looking the other way with all that
[ __ ] that person just said about sugar
these are not separate issues what you
have is a broken [ __ ] system which is
now going to take put duct tape on the
[ __ ] problem and go after innocent
[ __ ] people and for you to call me a
[ __ ] because you just sit there and you
oh these poor poor millionaires if
somebody's [ __ ] honest they shouldn't
have to [ __ ] pay for it look at the
Clintons look at the bushes look at the
Obamas look at them look how [ __ ]
corrupt they are the most they ever made
was four hundred [ __ ] five hundred
[ __ ] grand being President of the
United States and they're all worth
millions and millions and millions it
does go look go look at who they [ __ ]
give their speech to go look at his
first two [ __ ] speeches were to like
two of the biggest [ __ ] banks that
were behind the 2008 scandal and they're
going up vacuuming up all that [ __ ]
money it's [ __ ] Michelle Obama has
the [ __ ] balls to put out an
inspirational book on
to be a better [ __ ] person and make
your dreams come true she has all that
corporate money [ __ ] falling out from
between her [ __ ] titties get the [ __ ]
out of here what I want I want you to if
you're still listening what you I know
you are what a poor poor millionaires
well why do you why are you judging
somebody cuz they [ __ ] had the balls
to put their entire future on the
[ __ ] three zillion to one dog with
the limp at the back of the [ __ ] race
and the thing came in so now they have
to give away 70% of their money north of
ten million dollars listen if you're
saying that that's what the number is
and everybody's gonna pay 70% north you
know north of ten million dollars which
once again I'm not making so I'm
literally arguing for [ __ ] people
that I'm not okay but I plan on making
more than that and I'm in a country that
allows me to do it thank Christ all
right and I hope that you [ __ ] do it
someday and it's not my [ __ ] fault
that you don't have the [ __ ] balls or
an idea or the charisma or whatever the
[ __ ] you need to get to that level I
haven't had it yet but I'm not gonna
just because I haven't I'm not gonna
[ __ ] punish these other [ __ ]
people and here's the thing if every
[ __ ] in this country okay making
north of ten million dollars had to
[ __ ] pay that then you are going
somewhere but here's the [ __ ] thing
though
here's the thing though where is that
money gonna go are you gonna fix where
the [ __ ] it's gonna go because are you
gonna somehow fix our [ __ ] foreign
policy so we don't get broke fighting
thirty five hundred jerk-offs on a
[ __ ] jungle gym you're gonna ignore
all of those [ __ ] problems and just
take a select few group of [ __ ]
Americans who did nothing wrong made it
in a sports created a watch company
created a shaving company [ __ ]
created some something in their stand-up
act that [ __ ] made
enough Americans want to go to this show
that they're making you're gonna punish
them
you're gonna cosign on they have to give
away 70% of their [ __ ] money I just
can't get behind that and all of these
politicians blowing these [ __ ] people
who aren't paying [ __ ] taxes and then
they're gonna come out the other side
and then go give speeches to people who
don't pay [ __ ] taxes and companies
that don't pay [ __ ] taxes and take
that money and stick it in their [ __ ]
pocket and go buy themselves a big
mansion on [ __ ] Martha's Vineyard
that's all [ __ ] fine
un-fuckin'-believable and to sit there
and say that's separate issues that's
all tax issues that's all the same
[ __ ] issue anyways you said it isn't
fair that people being honest with their
income have to pay this rate while rich
people hide their income overseas you
also said tax money is being wasted on
corporate corporate [ __ ] I agree you
Paul I read this half a [ __ ]
paragraph that this person wrote you
said we should pay politicians [ __ ] you
money you don't think if that happens
even every money-grubbing corrupt [ __ ]
will do anything possible to run for
office and win an election including
promising corporations special deals and
in exchange for campaign so I I do
believe that I do believe that you've
been saying this for years yes I believe
that I can't believe nobody's call you
out on how [ __ ] stupid it is dude you
what you're doing is you're basically
gonna be like this well listen we can't
get these guys so let's get the people
we can get who haven't poisoned the food
supply who don't who don't dictate our
foreign policy yeah [ __ ] all of that
[ __ ] [ __ ] the twenty trillion dollars
sitting in the islands in the Caymans
let's go after the third baseman on the
New York Yankees yeah [ __ ] this guy this
doesn't make any sense dude what could
you can put a name and a face on that
[ __ ] guy and because he was better in
gym class than you you have this
underlying resentment that you call him
a poor
millionaire anyways he goes I think the
biggest issue is that you come from
comedy and you can't see beyond that
business yeah I seem to be talking about
a bunch of business here's don't I I'm
talking about our foreign policy I'm
talking about the food supply how much
further do I have to go I think everyone
in this country should be in the
position where their success is measured
by how hard they work and how much they
contribute that is mostly true in comedy
dude first of all I'll throw you a
hypocritical bowl of an out what the
[ __ ] do you know about comedy right I
know as much about comedy is manin I
don't know as much about your job as you
know about comedy so why is your opinion
on comedians more valid anyways if you
are a millionaire and your daddy was a
famous comedian notice how they use the
word daddy right that will only take you
so far in comedy if you're not funny
this is not true in every single
business for example if Donald Trump had
just invested his father's money in the
stock market he would be richer than he
is now
what the [ __ ] is that based on like what
is the stock market guaranteed you're
gonna make money the stock market is
corrupt but he's a very successful
hard-working man deserving of all our
empathy just like every other rich
[ __ ] yeah dude you know what you have
a problem with you have a problem with
anybody who's rich cuz you're all you're
putting all of them you're using all the
buzzwords daddy rich [ __ ] poor poor
millionaire anyways I graduated from
Harvard in 2015 I'm a public school
teacher one of the people you say tax
money should be going towards yes tax
money that was already collected sir
that was wasted on a never-ending
[ __ ] war
yes yes but let's not go after the
people that wasted that
let's take more tax dollars from
somebody who [ __ ] plays [ __ ] power
forward for the [ __ ] Cleveland
Cavaliers anyways unlike my classmates
making millions no matter how hard I
work no matter how much time I spend on
my students I don't earn another cent
over my $48,000 salary okay and did you
not know that going into that [ __ ]
business like what do you want me to do
here I don't think you should earn that
I think you should earn way more than
that but I don't think that regular
[ __ ] people who don't stick their
money in the cayman [ __ ] islands are
now required to pay for you because all
these other americans are paying no
taxes I don't I don't feel that that's
where that money should come from I feel
like you should make way more money than
that I think that you do one of the most
important jobs in this country and I
think you should get you should get paid
i I don't know 200 [ __ ] grand a year
to do it and I think you should have all
the supplies that you [ __ ] need I 100
I just don't agree with where you want
to get that money he goes I can earn
less than a thousand dollars in the next
year pay I can't believe you're a
[ __ ] teacher by the way by the way
you read you wrote this [ __ ] thing
but I'm gonna I'm gonna give you the
benefit of the doubt and say that you
were [ __ ] pissed off and [ __ ]
fired this thing off well this is a
giant voice text I can earn less than a
thousand in the next year pay increase
based on how my students do on statewide
standardized text test in fact if I want
to spend money on class material it
comes out of my own pocket can deduct a
maximum of 250 dollars a year meanwhile
some of the richest kant's in this
country are using their money to try and
make public schools worse yet I got to
tell you something dude these aren't the
guys you're gonna get with that 70% tax
thing and here's another thing dude
rather than call me a [ __ ] dumb
and a monkey hitting a [ __ ] keyboard
you know an idea that I had was I would
like to as a comedian to do there's
public schools in my [ __ ]
neighborhood here and I was walking by
one the other day
and I saw an auditorium and I'm thinking
wait a minute they have an auditorium
they got seats they got a stage why
don't I do a [ __ ] fundraiser for the
public school that was my thought and I
know I'm a mouth-breathing [ __ ] [ __ ]
dude you and I are on the same [ __ ]
team here and we should not be fighting
with each other we should be joining
forces and demanding that these corrupt
politicians go after all the all these
[ __ ] [ __ ] corporations and
individuals who pay no taxes rather than
[ __ ] as we're both like [ __ ]
trying to scamper out of the boiling
water point pulling each other down by
each other's ankles all right but here's
the funny [ __ ] thing it's the second
I thought about doing that show all I
thought was of the hashtags by the
[ __ ] parents and all of these [ __ ]
lunatics whose minds have been poisoned
by social media and all it's gonna take
is [ __ ] one of them to go out there I
can't do my [ __ ] act in a public
school auditorium in front of the
[ __ ] parents how the [ __ ] do I do
that I know how I do it what I do is I
get those cellphone bags and everybody
has to put their [ __ ] cell phones in
the [ __ ] bag before you go in there
that's how I'm gonna have to end up
doing it and unfortunately that's some
of the money that I could have given
that it could have given back to the
public school so here's the thing all
right sir
and I know you're not listening anymore
I'm gonna start doing those [ __ ]
shows I'm gonna start doing shows I'm
gonna pick a [ __ ] school and I'm
gonna give back that way that way
I would rather do it that way then
eventually having to pay 60% [ __ ]
taxes on my income because I'm already
paying 56 but that's just on my income
that's not property tax that's not
[ __ ] sales tax tax on gases all these
[ __ ] hidden taxes then I'm re paying
I'm lucky at this point if I'm keeping
30% of my [ __ ] money I would cringe
to see what the [ __ ] I'm paying in
[ __ ] taxes and I know you have no
sympathy for me because I had the
audacity to have my [ __ ] 301 [ __ ]
Greyhound come across the finish line
and I won and that you [ __ ] resent me
for that you know and you lump me in to
people and I'm not even at that [ __ ]
level all right but I've been around the
block enough times they ought to know
that if that 70% thing gets [ __ ]
passed dude they're not gonna stop at 10
and they're gonna keep going down so
what I got out of this is you know
something I'm gonna do one of those
[ __ ] shows at the public schools and
I'm gonna start doing those [ __ ]
things and I'm gonna get and I'm gonna
eat those [ __ ] cell phone bags and
I'll stick them in there and that's the
way that I'm gonna [ __ ] give back and
I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna get a
positive out of this all right and I
think what regular Americans need to do
which is what I still am and you can
[ __ ] demonize me all you want because
I'm finally [ __ ] making money 27
years into this [ __ ] [ __ ] all right
where the [ __ ] were you when I was
sitting on the futon waking up having
panic attacks when I had no manager no
[ __ ] agent and all agents were
telling me I had a weird look I used to
say to me by the way there is an
unwritten rule in this [ __ ] business
that if you are a redhead you are not
the lead in a movie I don't know if
that's gradually changing but I remember
I used to go to [ __ ] auditions and
like they would be prepared three scenes
it was back when I had a black-and-white
photo so I kind of looked like I had
brown hair it was the 90s they had
mousse in there oh right and I would
come in and as they looked at me I would
see the look on their face they big okay
we're just gonna read the first scene
yeah it's like dude you're redheaded
male you're not the lead you're the
friend you're the friend you're the one
who doesn't get the girl and all of that
[ __ ] [ __ ] so anyways we should be
helping each other out sir okay and is
the thing if I became a comedian and I
didn't make it I wouldn't be crying to
you about it okay
so you were the one who went to [ __ ]
Harvard and decided to become a public
school [ __ ] teacher you knew what the
deal was
okay that's what the [ __ ] you wanted to
do and I'm gonna believe you that you
went to Harvard and that you are a
public school teachers yeah you know on
the internet people can be like I
[ __ ] I hate Trump and I'm a
Republican people can do that all the
[ __ ] time I'm gonna take all his face
value and that you're actually a teacher
and that you wrote an email that was
filled with this many spelling mistakes
this this much [ __ ] hypocritical
behavior but you're yelling at me that I
can't see past the end of my own nose
you know the whole [ __ ] thing was
about you and your job and where the
[ __ ] you sit in the world I didn't
really see I didn't really see how you
were you were stepping outside of
yourself so here's the thing sir or
ma'am whoever [ __ ] wrote this thing
I'm gonna start doing that all right I'm
gonna start doing [ __ ] shows raising
money for some [ __ ] public and our
high schools or whatever get him some
money for some computers or whatever and
actually in a way I'd be helping myself
because I get a kid now and all the
public schools suck out here so now you
got to go to private schools from the
beginning you know and you're like
hundreds of thousands of dollars down
the [ __ ] drain because once again
people who didn't pay taxes and all the
money that all the money that we we are
all the money that they already [ __ ]
collect does not go where the [ __ ] it
should be so I appreciate your input I
hope you're mature enough to get you
know I hope you don't decide not to keep
listening to this podcast because of
something else because it sucks cuz it's
not funny because it got boring to you
after a while but if this is the reason
why that you're not listening you're
you're a [ __ ] baby you're a big
[ __ ] baby and you're really not
solving the [ __ ] problem and I think
it's really ignorant
to to demonize people that that made it
on their own made it in a sport started
a company you know but I draw the line
at you know if you made it in a sport
you don't pay taxes or you started a
company and now with that your next move
is to get your money outside the company
I don't support that and if a comedian
need to do that I don't support that I
don't
I love Willie Nelson not paying taxes
don't support that okay and I have no
problem paying my fair share and I think
at 56% plus all the others I think I'm
more than doing it unfortunately my tax
money that I'm paying is getting nowhere
near your school and that is not my
fault but that is the problem and those
are not separate issues from where I'm
from all right
that's so that's the podcast go [ __ ]
yourselves and I'm gonna you know I'm
gonna make do on my kit my campaign
promise I'm gonna find a [ __ ] school
and I'm gonna do it all right that's it
go [ __ ] yourselves and I'll see you on
Thursday